Molly McHugh has joined us on the
program before she is back today she is
a foreign policy and strategy consultant
also an information warfare expert she
had a really interesting article article
in Politico actually about the release
the memo hashtag which we've been
talking about quite a bit and Molly what
what you reported is that there actually
was significant bot activity behind that
memo and from the beginning it appeared
to me to be a very concerted sort of
distraction technique actually from the
substance of the of the FBI
investigation by robert muller talk to
us about how you first started following
this um well you know obviously we
started paying attention to it our team
here at new media frontier our new
company and we started paying attention
to this because it was being amplified
so quickly and it went from being
nowhere to being everywhere at the same
time and how that happens there's always
a really interesting process I think
there were some initial reports people
saying it's Russian bots pushing this
hashtag or it's something else pushing
this hashtag and and what that actually
is and how it happens it's much more
interesting process to begin to which is
why we started looking at it and I think
we lay out in the little go piece pretty
clearly that it's actually a blend of a
variety of different elements that came
together to make this campaign work
effectively there were Russian bots
there were other BOTS there were sort of
far-right information networks in the
u.s. engaged in these campaigns some of
the accounts are automated some of the
accounts are people some of the accounts
or send me automated so it's sort of a
layering on techniques and and tactics
to take a topic sort of organize a bunch
of a bunch of things behind it's the
same campaign and then target it at law
makers and others who are going to be
making decisions on this topic and so
it's sort of those three factors the
amplification the targeting and the
organization that were really effective
and how this worked how the how these
elements came together and worked very
effectively and achieving the outcome
they desired
can you talk a little bit about the
targeting piece
so a lot of the initial tweets that
started from sort of a very low level
network on Twitter we're tagging
Republican congressman either from the
House Intelligence Committee or some of
the more sort of pro-trump White House
defender voices on the hill so people
like that gets the Zeldin some were
tagging Paul Ryan as well so people who
were who were involved in lobbying their
Republican colleagues and and themselves
having to vote within the Intelligence
Committee on releasing the memo and
we're being heavily targeted by these
messages on social media so hundreds of
thousands of times over a week a week
and a half this was an active campaign
before the committee voted and that is
essentially an effective form of
influence and lobbying in terms of
getting a message in front of an elected
official and then getting them to act on
that information when we first mentioned
that there was a lot of bot activity
around this hashtag I would get sort of
anecdotal emails from people saying
David I used the hashtag and I was not
part of either a Russian coordinated
effort nor people lobbying members of
Congress or whatever else can you talk a
little bit about how maybe the term
useful idiot applies here and again
that's not an ad hominem that's actually
a term that has a very very specific
meaning where these campaigns don't
actually require the sort of
conspiratorial knowledge of all
participants to be effective no that's
that's exactly right and I think that
that's where these echo chambers are
really effective there is behind and
underneath a lot of what we see online
there is a lot more organization and
purposefulness that I think we often
admit there are on the far right and the
far left but more so on the far right
had been documented and discussed a lot
these sort of rooms and chat groups and
and sort of other organizational tools
that are being used by far right and all
right interests in the United States to
coordinate their messaging campaigns and
build them online and that does exist
but that's not to say everything is
behind
a puppet master you know once people are
have established networks on Twitter
they promote things from people they
know and trust
same on Facebook same on other social
media so once you build these structures
it's far easier to introduce information
to them and and get them to move in the
places that you want them to and I think
sometimes people just aren't aware of
how they are engaged in this however
their there are a lot of people that are
aware of what they're doing and the
combination of those things of real
people's accounts who are basically
semi-automated acting like human bots
themselves so their accounts
automatically follow and retweet and
move content from specific accounts from
specific narratives so you have accounts
of real people who were tweeting
released the memo a hundred times in a
day that is not normal behavior for any
one social media account so they're sort
of knowingly and purposefully acting and
saying we need to promote this to make
this trend and that is an interesting
element of the different pieces that we
were looking at because they're sort of
the human automation / amplification
side and the straight sort of bought
actual automated you know scripted by
algorithms side and the combination of
those two is very effective and the goal
of both of them is essentially to build
these trends to target people that will
see them and to get that information
into and promoted from verified accounts
because once you hit sort of get a
verified account to promote these on
Twitter can you talk a little bit about
the the sort of function of analytical
software to look through the usage and
the sort of pattern of usage of the
hashtag because people might hear you
and I talking now and they'll say ok it
must have you know Mollie McHugh
scrolling through a Twitter feed
manually is not going to give us
anything beyond sort of anecdotal
information but we're talking about the
use of actual analytical software to
examine this hashtag
are we not yeah absolutely and and we
have a combination
software that we're building ourselves
plus some of the commercially available
tools and some of it is sort of free
online things to do this but it's a we
looked at this in a variety of ways some
of it was scrolling through specific
accounts in painful detail trying to
figure out who they were what they were
where they came from
etc but you also have to look at the
volume over time a number of accounts
engaged and these campaigns how they
acted together sort of where the
information comes from where it gets
injected to how it gets promoted
ultimately over time and and that is
there's a variety of ways to do that the
software that visualized those things in
different ways to pull data from
different places but in particular for
this campaign it was useful for us to
have access to some of the stored
Twitter data there's a lot of the camp a
lot of the accounts that were engaged in
this campaign have either been deleted
or suspended or have deleted their own
content on the release the memo hashtags
since the memo was released which is
also interesting so you kind of need
these different elements coming together
to look at this and I think that one of
the best examples of this was there was
a bike a blogger or something but who
had published his own analysis of the
origins of release the memo but he got
it wrong because he didn't have access
to the information from the account that
have been released or blocked and and
that was important to have to be able to
look at the beginning of the campaign in
sort of layman's terms I think that this
succeeded in the sense that it did
significantly pull attention away from
the sort of subject matter of Robert
Moeller's investigation but also from
other stories that were not particularly
positive stories for Donald Trump and
for several days it really got a lot of
attention but that's just sort of me
taking like a generalist perspective how
would you assess the success of this
campaign in a variety of different ways
it was extremely successful and I think
in the base at the most basic level the
goal of establishing these types of
information networks through social
media or through other means is building
and using activation potential and in
this case it worked very effectively
you have
an extremely engaged community pushing
this narrative pushing this idea it
doesn't ultimately matter what the memo
was or what was in it I don't think it
changed anybody's mind about it one way
or the other but it was the the
organizing power of the idea of released
the memo has now created a very
comprehensive and detailed conspiracy
architecture into which a lot of the
narratives currently being pushed from
the same lanes make a lot of sense you
know the FBI is bad US intelligence is
bad the u.s. is surveilling its own
people this is bad and all of this kind
of fits into the talking points that you
hear coming unfortunately from the Oval
Office and from other right media in the
US but this one hashtag became kind of
organizing principle in people's heads
for for how this made sense so it was
extremely effective variety of ways how
else might we measure it in other words
are there any numerical comparisons that
can be made or what what else do you
look at when you're sort of looking at
the spread of the hashtag well there
were a couple of things that we were
using to look at how widespread or
effectiveness was one was on the
targeting East for Congress and I think
the the volume there spoke it said a lot
there were hundreds of thousands of
tweets targeting members on the
committee before they voted to release
the memo and if you compare that to sort
of a very active period when there would
have been constituents like actual
people calling into congressional
offices about health care about you know
the tax bill about some folks it's
happening that people want to have their
voices heard on this was you know three
times that amount of volume per day in
some cases in terms of how many messages
an individual member would have been
getting so the perception for them would
have been this is something that has a
tremendous amount of support behind it
even if they don't know what the origins
of that are there there are Twitter
mentions and timelines would have been
totally flooded by this concept and that
does make an impression on how people
think about these things the other thing
we tried to compare the release the memo
campaign to two other sort of similarly
timed events that were actually
happening the 2018 women's March and NFL
playoff game that was that week
and if you look at the total volume of
tweets that were coming from over a
similar period of time so about eight
hours of time if you look at the total
volume of tweets coming from what we
know were around women a million women
and other participants engaging in these
demonstrations and then a lot of people
watching a very popular national
football event in both cases those were
you know a third or less a third or less
of the volume of tweets as the release
the memo hashtag was getting when it was
being promoted and I think that's that's
really significant that that initial
that initial ramped up phase was so
quick but it was happening late at night
but it was happening primarily without
the engagement of some of the big
amplifiers that we all know know Hannity
people like that they were engaged very
late in the campaign this was coming
from other places or the big voices got
involved checkout Molly McHugh's article
in Politico how Twitter BOTS and Trump
fans made release the memo go viral
Molly thanks as always for talking to us
thanks for having me on